and so what is metapurse fund this is
your
uh fund to buy nfts or to invest in
startups or some combinations
it's roughly a 200 million dollar fund
that you're investing out of
yeah so um again it didn't start out as
a 200 million dollar fund uh
i took some of the money i uh made
through crypto
and i started buying nfts right like for
two reasons one of them
i had this base thesis of the virtual
worlds
and i looked at them as a new
distribution platform
where i feel like the new social media
will not look like the same social media
so it's going to be different and so i
started investing in all these virtual
worlds and
and buying up like scores of land so
that's
that's how uh that started so that was
back in 2017
and that's part of the fun now right and
uh i've also invested in
all the infrastructure companies and and
and all these nft related companies
not in dapper labs but in flow right
like i kind of have this uh
tendency to to trust the tokens more
than the
underlying company itself personally
because liquidity interesting
you trust the token more than the
company i
as an investor in startups was insistent
when
a number of my startups asked to do icos
that my investment remained in the
company
and that if i wanted to buy some tokens
i would do that but i took the opposite
approach so who who's going to turn out
to be right in this one do you think
so so it depends right like uh not not
every company is going to have a
successful token
definitely uh but i i i have very few
investments but
all of them are you know like well
thought of and and um
like high impact to an extent there are
a few that didn't work out
but for me personally i i've moved
myself into singapore i have no capital
gains
that means that you know i can roll over
my money so
like accumulation is very different here
right so i get to do a 10x
and then take the money do it another
10x i don't think that's the same
across the world uh no you would have to
pay capital gains and you would have to
pay short-term capital gains in fact
so in singapore you can just move in and
out of cryptocurrencies
all day long and flip them without
having the tax event correct
um not if you are you know actively
trading
actively trading then becomes a business
you know it and and
you're treated like that's your business
and you have to pay income on it
but you know i i never trade right i
move from investments to an investment
got it so wait you're saying you never
sell your digital assets
or you use your digital asset to buy the
other
yeah that's right so i i i i have
no fiat uh i don't live on fiat at all
so i i just moved from say this
route right like i moved from ethereum
to dot to flow and and there was
not much happening there uh and so
you have no fiat what do you do when you
go to dinner or you have to pay your
rent or buy a house
i do have a personal bank account in
singapore nowadays it's a little more
easy
to get the account uh last two years was
a little hard i should tell you
but you know and there are also these uh
crypto cards right like
crypto.com and 10x and various stuff
so i've been swiping that away so it's
not been hard